hm du hast dich ja dr beschwert in
Interviews werden immer dieselben Fragen
gestellt da haben wir aber eine Maßnahme
gegen man kann selber sich fragen
aussuchen richtig aber so halbblind die
roten sind unverschämte Fragen die
Grünen sind harmlose Fragen direkt
unverschämt und
ja dar Fragen lottus ihr darf selber
ziehen Vorlesen aber mich wieder mir
Antworten dann kann ich auch eine
Nachfrage mal Stellen in der ersten
Partie spielt einracht
Frankfurt gegen Spanien gegen Spanien
soll ich ich auch in die Kamera halten
kannst du auch in die Kamera halten was
steht denn
da eine Frage an dich als spätzeugender
geht ein Säugling in diesem Alter nicht
an die Substanz es ist schon in deinem
Alter gemeint also auf an deine Substanz
in deinem
Alter das war die Frage Z jetzt ne 38
bin ich werde dieses Jahr 39 fühle mich
ich habe die Kraft der zwei Herzen fühle
mich Jünger denn je merke aber war dass
ähm mittlerweile Ärzte und Politiker auf
Plakaten jünger sind als ich das macht
mich ein wenig unsicher ähm nee gar
nicht ich freue mich ohne Ende auf auf
auf unseren Nachwuchs und ähm ich fühle
mich wirklich noch jung und keine Ahnung
erste Kind ich glaube so ein hält auch
jung und keine Ahnung wir werden ja
demnächst alle 100 Sportsfreunde ne wir
werden ja alle alle so alt wie Johannes
h das jetzt schon ist und das heißt da
bin ich jetzt in der Pubertät eigentlich
und demnächst wird das ja so sein dass
da 75-Jährige Frauen in der in der Bahn
aufstehen müssen weil die die Jüngsten
sind die überhaupt im Abteil sitzen
irgendwo also ich habe alle Hoffnung gut
ich habe nur ein ich stell mir vor dre
monatskolik vor der Sendung verstehen
sie Spaß kaum geschlafen 20:15 Uhr oh
Gott ich brauche noch eine Aspirin Tipp
oder Trick gute
Maskenbildnerin
die gibt Stifte um Augenringe
wegzumachchen der heißt glaub ich auch
CCH oder sogar ganz lustig und das geht
super und mein Gott ist eben so ne ja
kriegen wir h also ich glaube mit
Unterstützung geht das schon gut
okay ach
so gibt mir dann gibt das nicht so
durcheinander bisschen W okay ich nehme
jetzt mal eine
grüne gegen Hansa
Rostock du machst ja Werbung für Köln
Port ist das der Nabel der
Welt würde ich nee Nabel der Welt ist
vielleicht übertrieben obwohl das ja
eine Sache ist das sieht jeder anders
das ist meine Heimat ich bin hier
geboren wohne seitdem in Ports und
glaube dass wir uns gar nicht so
verstecken müssen haben ein Flughafen
bei uns gibt es die deutsche luft- und
raumfahrtgesellschaft und viel Grün und
den reinen badesstrand also noch mal
hier also Freunde das ist fast der
baller
also ich find Ports gut der Nabel der
Welt ist es nicht und ich kann nur jedem
raten Fahrt so viel wie möglich in die
Welt guckt euch Leute an und
verschiedene Länder und hört euch
verschiedene Sprachen an nicht nur zu
Hause rumsitzen so toll der Computer ist
aber mal man muss Leuten die Hand
schütteln irgendwo in Aserbaidschan da
war ich jetzt auch noch nicht aber ich
glaube das bringt einen weiter gut du
darfst noch so wie viel du möchtest
ichch mal
unverschämte die sind übrigens
geklöppelt worden vom hiigen
Kindergarten glaube
ich
oh ist dein Dauergrinsen echt
Fragezeichen ja ich bin natürlich wenn
man Fotos macht lächelt man ja das ist
ja klar da sagen die auch gerne zeig mal
deine Zähne die sind auch noch echt aber
ich bin ein fröhlicher Mensch da kann
ich nichts für stehe meistens morgens
auf und habe gute Laune und bin sehr
positiv und sehr optimistisch und glaube
auch dass der liebe Gott auf mich
aufpasst mm und gibt nicht Leute denen
das mal auf den Geist gegangen ist das
ist mir total scheißegal natürlich ist
Gido kannz anstrengend und ich kann auch
sagen verstehen le sag der plappert den
ganzen Tag jeder ist anders ich habe
mich auch nicht selber gemacht bin
ebenso deine Freunde kommen alle damit
zurecht ach die werden die sind auch mal
genervt bestimmt aber das also ich bin
jemand ich möchte nur jedem was Gutes
ich bin überhaupt nicht berechnend und
geh offen auf Leute zu und Hof immer
dass alle Leute ehrlich und offen auch
auf mich
zugehen gut ah die roten sind besser
roten ja ja
klar die roten sind
besser
Moment die die kurzen da rein
Trommelwirbel
Moment hast du eigentlich
irgendeine Ausbildung zu Ende gebracht
Fragezeichen natürlich also ich habe mal
Abitur gemacht ja 1990 das heißt in
diesem Jahr 20jähriges ich freue mich
drauf am 11 September treffen wir uns wo
weiß ich noch nicht
m dann war ich bei der Bundeswehr viele
haben das vielleicht schon mal gehört
ja obergefrah der Reserve war ich da
habe mich viel verdruckt und war auf der
Bekleidungskammer in koblens ein
spannendes
Geschäftsfeld und danach habe ich BWL
studiert an der Universität zu Köln sech
Semester habe aber dann abgebrochen und
von den sechs waren es glaube ich eher
drei die man vielleicht so sich wirklich
da aufschreiben darf ich habe so ein
Fernstudium gemacht ich war viel zu
Hause und hatte mit mir selber eine
Abmachung ich find es heute echt lustig
mittlerweile damals meinte ich das ernst
bin morgens zur Uni gefahren und da gab
es so ein Parkhaus rund um das
Unigebäude und dann habe ich gesagt wenn
ich jetzt keine keinen Parkplatz bekomme
dann möchte der liebe Gott nicht dass
ich heute studiere und ich war viel zu
Hause du bist sehr Gottes sehr
gottesfürchtig gewesen ich habe danach
1994 begonnen eine schulische Ausbildung
zu machen und darf mich heute staatlich
geprüfter kaufmännischer medienassistent
schimpfen was auch immer das ist es ging
auf jeden Fall Richtung
Fernsehproduktion Produktionsleitung und
das habe ich 1996 nach Z Jahren beendet
mit einem sehr guten Zeugnis um mich zu
beruhigen dass ich eine Pappe habe habe
aber nie richtig gearbeitet muss ich
dazu sagen hast du da auch irgendwas
gelernt
ja mit zehn Fingern zu schreiben ich
kann mit Zeh Fingern tippen das weiß ich
noch
super aber langsam oder eininigermaßen
schnell nee schnell gut das ist gut wenn
man Texte schreibt ist das das da bin
ich sehr froh drüber sonst war ich auch
Montags z.B nicht ganz so oft
da blöder Tag
montags ja die roten sind besser gute
Fragen
komm
war die Moderation von verstehen sie
Spaß ein Rettungsanker kannst du mir die
erklären die Frage ja die kann ich
erklären weil zwischendurch gab's glaube
ich keinen
fernseheinsatz so nach dem Motto endlich
wieder Fernsehen ach so
nee nee nee ne also ich habe keine
eigene Sendung gehabt nach 2008 bis
jetzt
Anfang 2010 das ist richtig habe aber
genug Fernsehen gemacht dass man als
Gast irgendwo war und so da gibt's keine
Probleme und
ich hätte hatte auch ein paar Angebote
so ist es auch nicht aber ich wollte zu
hören hinaus nee ich wollte gar nicht zu
hören hinaus ich wollte was machen wo
ich genau sage da stehe ich zu und da
stehe ich auch hinter und ich hatte
2009 ein Fernsehformat was ich auch
moderiert hätte ein comedyformat was
leider ganz kurz vor Vertragsabschluss
nicht geklappt hat was mir auch große
Freude bereitet hätte und das war lange
in der Schwebe deswegen nee war ich auch
sehr zufrieden
daz muss man sagen ich glaube gefühlte
90% vom Formaten sind immer kurz vor
Ausstrahlung wenn dann die die se ne das
stimt nee ne ne das stimmt so nicht ich
habe ja gefühlte gesagt das das gibt es
alles ich habe viele pilotsendungen
gemacht in meinem Leben aber das war
eine Sendung wo der Pilot diese
pilotsende super war
und nur noch die Tinte eigentlich unter
den Vertrag den gab's auch schon es gab
Termine und auch das ist dann irgendwann
dann irgendwie ich hab schon mal eine
Sendung gemacht da gab schon
Sendetermine und eine Million war schon
ausgegeben und sie haben wir hatten nur
wir hatten 28 Sendetermine aber hat noch
kein Geld ausgegeben und dann wurde dann
gesagt na das dauert noch eine Woche und
dann irgendwann was vorbei was okay ist
man lernt dadurch aber
das war auch so dass ich deswegen bei
verstehen sie Spaß bis zur ersten
Sendung nie eine Pulle aufgemacht habe
ich Gesagte ich glaube das erst
definitiv wenn ich da am 10 April in
Halle stehe und gesag guten Abend sage
und ja man lernt dadurch gut man wird
sehr geduldig und vorsichtig wenn
verstehen sie Spaß ein Rettungsanker ist
dann kann man noch zufrieden sein würde
ich sagen ja das stimmt okay noch eine
rote od eine rot noch W ich ge dir das
zurü die hier drüben das
ist ja da sind ja ja das SE gut jetzt
haben
wir oh jetzt jetzt wir pass mal auf
jetzt wird investigativ wie fühlt man
sich beim Rentner TV ich vermute damit
ist ARD gemeint ja und der
südwestrundwunk der S und damit
verstehen sie Spaß ich fühle mich da
super wohl und muss allerdings
zugeben dass ich
mit anderen Erwartung dahingegangen bin
und positiv überrascht wurde ich habe ja
vorher eigentlich nur mit
Privatfernsehen oder viel
Privatfernsehen gemacht wobei ich seit
10 eine Sendung im ZDF auch mal
moderiere das mache ich auch immer noch
und die Redaktion ist Klasse man kann D
sehr gut einbringen man wird gehört und
die Leute die da arbeiten haben viele
die echt Ahnung haben also klar ist dass
Sendung die Sendung wie verstehen sie
Spaß in zuschauerklientel hat von 55
plus aber dafür bin ich glaube ich auch
eingekauft worden dass wir versuchen
jüngere Leute auch durch Facebook durch
Twitter und durch Lena Meer landtr
solche Gäste die auch näher an die
Sendung ranzuführen und
ja das ist meine Aufgabe und da freue
ich mich drauf und natürlich immer so
ein bisschen Spagat ja man darf die Oma
aus Oma kalupke aus
Eisenhüttenstadt nicht vergessen genauso
wenig
wie Justin aus portslangel mit 17 schön
wenn die alle einschalten würden das
heißt Bushido wä kein guter Gast für
euch Bushido wird bei mir s nicht
stattfinden solange ich das
moderiere das kann ich guten Gewissen
sagen okay dann viel Erfolg mit vielen
anderen nettenesten natürlich
jo